Luria was inspired to try to address the question of whether mutations actually happened
spontaneously,
or whether they were induced by the environment.
One question that immediately pops to mind was, what was so special about this guy,
Salvador Luria, that allowed him to solve the problem that nobody else could solve before him.
And it builds on a general theme of, you know, problem solvers,
probably in science but anywhere else,
which is that, he brought a fresh perspective to the problem,
and his fresh perspective was that he was a trained physicist.
And so being a physicist,
he thought about biology through quantitative, sort of mathematical ways,
which was different from biologists who were largely involved in drawing descriptive
diagrams of, you know, what a feather looked like, or recording where
species were found and in what environment.
That unusual perspective made
him approach, methodologically,
the problem very different from everybody else.
Luria chose to approach this problem through bacteria
and their sensitivity to viruses that kill them.
And this was,
you know,
really an amazing leap at the time because of the fact that
bacteria were not perceived to be relevant to the kinds of
traits which had driven the question in the first place.
So people,
as I said,
saw,
you know,
apes all looked like the same,
but they occasionally would evolve to become a human,
and how could bacteria provide any insight into that question,
was a major leap by him, that there
was some commonality between what bacteria do with their genetic material and what
complex organisms do with theirs.
The bacteria were thought to be,
you know,
very simple single cell organisms that you could argue didn't even
have a trait;
all they were was they generated more bacteria.
So where is the trait involved there?
But
people knew that not all bacteria were the same, that they did acquire things, which seem to be
genetically inheritable, that distinguished them.
And one trait that bacteria could acquire that made them different from any other, was
their ability to be resistant to a virus that would kill
them. Like the viruses that infect us,
there are many different types of viruses that infect bacteria.
And there was a particular virus that was useful to bacteria,
which was called T1.
It was a virus that could,
after it bound to the surface,
proliferate within a cell within twenty minutes, and cause the cell to lyse and die.
It was a killing machine. And, however,
it wasn't quite true that all bacteria were killed, there were a few that survived this
onslaught of exposure to T1.
And it turns out that if you took those few bacteria that
survived, and you allowed them to propagate and
produce lots of babies, lots of progenies, all the babies,
the progeny, also were no longer sensitive to the presence of the T1 in the
solution.
So these rare bacteria that arose that were unable to be killed by
the virus were able to provide-- this trait could then be
inherited to all their progeny afterwards.